una mujer que va en bicicleta su trabajo
siguiendo un camino junto a unas vías
del tren a una velocidad de 6 kilómetros
por hora
creo que este dato es importante cada
día ella llega al cruce al mismo tiempo
que llega el tren ella llega a un cierto
closer al mismo tiempo que llega el tren
y un día ella sale 50 minutos tarde y es
superada por el tren a 6 kilómetros del
cruce la pregunta es en cuántos minutos
llegará el tren al cruce y bueno pues
vamos a intentar hacer un diagrama o un
dibujo para ver qué es lo que está
pasando y entender un poco mejor el
problema así que hablemos de un día
normal en un día normal ella recorre
este camino al lado de las vías del tren
que por cierto es muy parecido a lo que
me pasa a mí yo también voy con mi
propia bicicleta en un camino al lado de
unas vías del tren pero bueno ella va
hasta su trabajo al lado de unas vías
del tren y voy a suponer que aquí
empieza su recorrido por lo tanto aquí
es el tiempo igual a cero aquí este de
aquí va a ser el cruce y por aquí pasa
el tren
adelante y adelante y bueno lo que me
dicen es que ella va a una velocidad de
6 kilómetros por hora y entonces no me
dan ni la distancia que tengo aquí ni me
dan en cuánto tiempo hace este recorrido
sin embargo lo que voy a suponer porque
me importa el tiempo y mi pregunta es
algo que tiene que ver con el tiempo voy
a suponer que este recorrido lo hace la
mujer que va en bicicleta en a horas es
decir que todo este recorrido completo
lo hace en a horas hay que tener cuidado
con el tiempo es muy importante este
recorrido lo hace en a horas y bueno eso
es lo que pasa en un día común pero un
día ella se levanta y hace todas sus
actividades 50 minutos tarde por lo
tanto vamos a hablar de otro día de este
día especial en este día especial ella
comienza con un tiempo de 50 minutos
retrasados y cuantos 50 minutos a
comparación de una hora pues 50 entre 60
es lo mismo que 5 sextos es decir
empieza en un tiempo de 5 sextos
va a empezar 51 sextos después de lo que
empieza normalmente su recorrido así que
este tiempo de inicio va a ser 5 sextos
de hora 5 sextos de hora y bueno que
otra cosa dice el problema
ella es superada por el tren a 6
kilómetros del cruce a 6 kilómetros del
cruce nos preguntan en cuánto tiempo el
tren llegará al cruce empresas que voy a
suponer que aquí es en el momento en el
que el tren y ella se encuentran ese día
especial que por cierto es a 6
kilómetros del cruce la distancia que
hay de que acá son 6 kilómetros si yo lo
que quiero saber es en cuántos minutos
el tren va a llegar al cruce a partir de
este punto en lo que me tengo que fijar
es que si el tren cruce en este punto
justo en un tiempo de a horas si
nosotros nos tomamos la diferencia entre
el tiempo te igualan y sabemos en qué
tiempo se cruzan este día especial
entonces vamos a ver en cuánto tiempo va
a recorrer el tren lo que falta así que
vamos a ver si podemos determinar este
tiempo fíjate bien lo primero que quiero
que veas es que de aquí acá
hay seis kilómetros llegaba a una
velocidad
de 6 km programa por lo tanto todo esto
ella lo va a recorrer en una hora como
ella va a una velocidad promedio de 6
kilómetros por hora esto lo va a
recorrer en una hora muy bien y entonces
si todo este trayecto lo recordé en
horas pues bueno este otro pedacito este
otro pedazo de trayecto lo va a recorrer
ella en a menos una hora si todo lo
recorre en a horas entonces de aquí acá
hay al menos 1 hora porque aquí le falta
una hora para llegar al cruce donde
siempre se encontraba con el tren
entonces déjenme bajar la pantalla este
tiempo es de al menos 1 horas muy bien
ya con esta información entonces ahora
quiero que te des cuenta cómo vamos en
los tiempos fíjate bien ella empezó en
este día especial 5 sextos de hora más
tarde
entonces en qué tiempo estamos parados
justo aquí bueno pues en este tiempo
estamos a 5 sextos porque ya empezó 5
sextos más tarde más el tiempo que ya ha
viajado a
de este punto el tiempo que haya viajado
hasta este punto habíamos quedado que
era a menos 1 horas y que cree eso yo
creo que ya tenemos el conocimiento
suficiente y todos los datos la
información para poder resolver este
problema porque fíjate bien en un día
normal el tren y la mujer se intersectan
en un tiempo de a horas después de que
la mujer empezó su recorrido
ahora se interceptaron en un tiempo de 5
sextos más o menos 1 porque nuestra
protagonista se despertó 50 minutos más
tarde entonces yo me tomo la diferencia
entre el tiempo normal en el que ellos
dos se cruzan y el tiempo actual en el
que se cruzaron voy a obtener en cuánto
tiempo les falta el tren para llegar al
cruce donde originalmente se encuentran
y para esto no voy a tomar entonces esta
diferencia aunque es el tiempo de
siempre menos 5 sextos más a menos 1 que
es el tiempo en donde ahora se
encontraba en este día especial y cuánto
me queda de esto me queda a menos 5
sextos menos a más 1 y perfecto porque
está y está se va y solamente me queda
uno menos 5 sextos y esto está dado en
horas
por cierto es un sexto un sexto de hora
es lo que le falta al tren recorrer para
llegar al cruce donde siempre se
encuentran pero un sexto de hora es diez
minutos por lo tanto ya tengo la
respuesta al tren le faltan diez minutos
para llegar al cruce y perfecto porque
ya con esto podemos encontrar hasta la
velocidad del tren que podría ser otra
variante de este mismo problema pero en
fin otro problema viene así que nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo